>> Sean: JOINING US NOW WITH
REACTION TO TONIGHT'S OPENING
BREAKING NEWS, JOE DIGENOVA,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR ANDREW
McCARTHY, AND OF COURSE HE
WRITES FOR THE NATIONAL REVIEW,
ALSO.
THE SMARTEST PERSON I KNOW.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
SO, STRZOK GOES BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS AND SAYS HE'S GOING TO
TALK, I DON'T KNOW IF I BELIEVE
IT.
>> I THINK HE SOUNDS LIKE HE'S
ONE OF THESE GUYS THAT THINKS HE
CAN GO INTO THE ROOM AND KIND OF
CONTROL THE ROOM.
HOROWITZ SAID HE HAD VERY
INVOLVED ANSWERS, SO HE MAY JUST
AND IT DO OKAY.
HE'S GOT REASONS TO THINK THAT.
BECAUSE IN A COURT ROOM, WHERE
THERE IS A JUDGE, SOMEBODY CAN'T
GET AWAY WITH JUST GIVING THEIR
SIDE OF THE STORY AND THEN
SAYING, WHEN YOU TRY TO
CROSS-EXAMINE HIM, NATIONAL
SECURITY REASONS, OR
INVESTIGATIVE INTEGRITY.
STORY, NOW THEY GET TO ASK YOU
ABOUT THE HARD STUFF.
IN A CONGRESSIONAL HEARING, THEY
CAN DODGE THAT STUFF, THEY GET
AWAY WITHOUT ALL THE TIME.
>> I HAVE SOME FAITH WITH A FEW
OF THE CONGRESSMEN THERE.
YOU KNOW, ONE THING YOU SAID, IT
STILL STICKS WITH ME.
SO MANY OF MY -- MY MOM WAS A
PRISON GUARD, MY DAD WORKED IN
FAMILY COURT PROBATION.
MY COUSINS WERE ON THE NYPD.
THE TWO COUSINS WERE COPS.
THEY BEGAN THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION WHICH I WOULD
ARGUE RENDERS IT ILLEGITIMATE
FROM THE GET-GO.
THIS IS THE GUY YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT, AND AS I SAID FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING OF THIS, JAMES
COMEY WAS A DIRTY COP.
MR. STRZOK IS DIRTIER.
HE'S GOING TO GO IN TOMORROW AND
HE IS GOING TO LIVE.
HE'S GOING TO GIVE EXPLANATIONS
THAT ARE UNTRUTHFUL.
ABOUT PRESIDENT OR CANDIDATE
TRUMP.
HE CAN'T WIN, CAN HE?
HE CAN'T HAVE HIM AS PRESIDENT.
NOW HE IS CLAIMING THAT THERE IS
AN EXPLANATION FOR HER, WE WILL
STOP HIM.
I CAN'T WAIT TO HEAR IT.
>> YOU KNOW WE DON'T LIKE YOU
ARE TO PEOPLE I WOULDN'T WANT TO
MESS WITH IN COURT ROOM.
I KIND OF AGREE BUT THEN THERE
IS THE INSURANCE POLICY.
THEN THERE IS A LOATHSOME HUMAN
BEING.
THEN THERE ARE THE ACTIONS.
NOW IT'S REAL.
AND THERE ARE SOME SUPERIOR
BELIEVE THAT HE'S DOING IT FROM
NOBLE CAUSES, BUT REALLY, HE IS
ALMOST ATTEMPTING A COUP,
BECAUSE SOMEONE WAS GUILTY OF
CRIMES THAT HE PUSHES UNDER THE
RUG.
THEY GO FULL FORCE SLEDGEHAMMER
ON THE OTHER CANDIDATE.
AT THAT TO ME IS INFLUENCING AN
ELECTION AND COLLUSION.
>> LET'S BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT
THIS.
THIS IS NOT A COMPLICATED CASE.
AT THE FBI OF THE SENIOR LEVELS
OF THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE,
LORETTA LYNCH AND ALL HER
MINIONS HAD TWO GOALS IN MIND.
VERY SIMPLE, VERY PLAIN.
EXONERATE HILLARY CLINTON
ILLEGALLY AND IF SHE LOCKED
STOMACH LOST THE ELECTION,
THAT'S IT.
IN A NUTSHELL IT'S NEVER CHANGED
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS AND
EVERYTHING THAT WE HAVE LEARNED
FROM THE TEXT MESSAGES, THE IG
REPORTS, HAS PROVEN CONCLUSIVELY
AND THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
PEOPLE WANTED TO DO.
AND IT WON'T MAKE MUCH
DIFFERENCE.
>> I THINK IT'S CLEAR THAT THESE
WERE TWO INVESTIGATIONS GOING ON
AT THE SAME TIME, AND WHETHER
YOU ARE A LIBERAL OR DEMOCRATIC,
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU LOOK AT
THEM AND SAY THE SAME QUALITY OF
JUSTICE WAS ACCORDED TO BOTH.
THE LAW.
EQUAL APPLICATION OF THE LAW, IN
OUR CONSTITUTION.
THE BIGGEST MOST OBVIOUS CASE OF
OBSTRUCTION, THEY MADE EVERY
CONSIDERATION.
THREAD EVERY NEEDLE, EVEN THOUGH
PEOPLE WENT TO JAIL.
PROTOCOL, FOUR TIMES USING
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR POLITICAL
RESEARCH.
>> ON ONE SIDE OF THE COIN WITH
HILLARY, IT LOOKS LIKE THEY BENT
OVER BACKWARDS TO NOT MAKE THE
CASE.
AND ON THE OTHER SIDE, WHERE YOU
DON'T HAVE EVIDENCE OF A CRIME,
IT SEEMS THAT THEY SCORCHED THE
EARTH TO TRY TO STOP THIS
PRESIDENCY.
>> Sean: THAT TO ME IS A IS A
TENT AN ATTEMPT AT BYPASSING THE
DEEPER THAN ANYTHING WE WOULD
IMAGINE WITH WATERGATE AND
WHAT THE FBI AND THE DO    DOJ A
WHAT THE FBI AND THE DO    DOJ D
WHAT THE FBI AND THE DO    DOJ T
SUBVERSION.
THEY SOUGHT TO SUBVERT AN
ELECTION, AND WHEN THE PERSON
THAT THEY DIDN'T WANT GOT
THEY HAVE DONE EVERYTHING IN
THEIR POWER, AND EVEN THOUGH
PETER STRZOK IS TESTIFYING
THE CIA DIRECTOR IN COOPERATION
WITH CLAPPER.
NONE OF THIS WILL BE FAIR UNLESS
BOTH OF THEM FIND THEMSELVES IN
FRONT OF A GRAND JURY.
>> I THINK YOU WILL HAVE A LOT
TO SAY TOMORROW BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS, BUT I WILL LET THE TEXT
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES.
>> SHOULD THEY RELEASE THE
TRANSCRIPT?
CONGRESS HAS THE POWER TO MAKE
THAT.
>> I ASSUME THEY ARE ASKING
QUESTIONS BEHIND CLOSED DOORS
BECAUSE THEY MAKE IT INTO
CLASSIFIED MATTERS, BUT I THINK
OFTEN DO?
>> WHAT THEY ARE GOING TO COME
UP WITH THINK JIM JORDAN'S THAT
HE REGARDS THIS AS STEP NUMBER
ONE.
SO IT'S STEP ONE AND THEN WILL
BE A PUBLIC HEARING.
>> I THINK THESE PEOPLE WILL GO
TO JAIL AND ITS WORST ABUSE OF
POWER WE'VE EVER SEEN.